hey everyone else going this is final
fantasy 15 windows edition I'm John Luke
and I got a chance to play some of it at
PAX West over here and gonna be honest
with you not very impressed so we're
running the game 1080p on a PC I don't
know the graphics settings of the PC
like what card I had or anything I
didn't even get a chance to actually
look at what the game was running at
there was no in-game menu at all for
graphics settings being employed just
that kind of stuff I would hope that the
final product would be able to have that
but I wasn't able to check what kind of
you know like anti-aliasing or shadows
or shaders the gamepad which was pretty
disappointing but the you know got to
play the game got to play on mouse and
keyboard and that is probably the first
thing about this game is that all of the
UI is still listed for controller
supports so I had a very hard time just
trying to play the game on mouse and
keyboard they had a little card sheet
that I could kind of look at but that's
not really the best way to play so when
the game pops up and says you know press
circle button to do something I have to
try and figure out what key that is and
that was really frustrating and then in
general the default key bindings didn't
seem great I had to press tab of all
things to sprint which is just not ideal
and stuff like that just kind of makes
it feel like a not an amazing PC port
you know like I'd PC players expect all
that customization and options and not
having that at least in this build was
not a great sign but yeah I mean the
game looks it still looks nice it looks
like Final Fantasy 15 I would have to
look side-by-side but it didn't seem too
much better like from my memory of the
original game nothing about this like
struck me as like wow this looks so much
better and part of it is the frame rate
it doesn't seem like it's got a
rock-solid frame rate at spots it runs
fine but then in combat it was it was
getting it was chugging a lot and that
is something I would at the very least
expect would be able to run this game I
like that a solid like 60 frames the
resolution we were only running at 1080p
as well
again I don't know what the graphics
card in the hardware was but there's no
reason the game shouldn't be able run at
60 I feel like home machine so I don't
know if it just isn't optimized yet or
if they had certain settings turned off
but again for a very first impression on
the PC I really wasn't that impressed
kind of disappointed in it so yeah I'm
just gonna let a couple minutes of
gameplay run to show you guys and you
liked this video make sure to hit sub
and give us a follow it really helped us
out and thanks for watching
[Music]
well if it isn't Sonya huh somebody you
know spoke with her just the ones back
at hammerhead now that you mention it
you were chatting someone up
she's real knowledgeable about wildlife
could teach us a thing or two go on and
introduce yourself
[Music]
[Music]
ah what is it now if you don't mind I'm
rather busy at the moment
oh it's you boys wait who are you again
and what do you need now nothing hmm
you're saying you distracted me for
nothing this won't do
won't do at all precious seconds down
the drain how am I to make up for them
of course you boys can help me that's
the spirit I was just thinking I could
use a few extra hands after catching
frogs to be precise wait what
Fox oh and if you're thinking any old
frog will do wrong you're not getting
off that easily
only the Red Frog native to austere
suits my needs you need to get me an
elbow deep down at the soup with that
I'll get back to my work remember
it's red frogs and make sure they're
fresh
[Music]
that was overwhelming hmm
let's hope it will be edifying as well
how did you men welcome to the crow's
nest grab some food before you go
[Music]
so you think you're pretty tough huh
knock them dead
take a look at the menu hold on just a
second Bon Appetit
[Music]
we'll see you around
[Music]
[Music]
seems we found what we were looking for
resting on you now I feel lost
[Music]
go get us some dinner
[Music]
yeah
not back me up
[Music]
[Music]
together cheetah
[Music]
[Music]
plenty of to it
that's crossing the line
right there
turn
[Music]
yeah
look watch yourself No
on top of it
[Music]
but watch out you're up
nice one
[Music]
to a fight
yeah
Thanks
that's it
what's up biggie I've come up with a new
recipe I can't wait to try it
what
yeah